the 19th century french emperor napoleon
bonaparte
purportedly once called chyna a sleeping
lion
let her sleep he warned for when she
wakes she will
shake the world
200 years later in 2014 the new chinese
president xi jinping was invited to
paris
and he referenced that quote from
napoleon
this lion has awakened he said but it is
peaceful
civilized and friendly
though some would beg to differ
for years china has had complete
impunity
on the world stage even as its human
rights record despite its rhetoric
was worsening for decades many in the
west hoped china would grow into a
trusted ally
perhaps even a democracy instead an
emboldened
beijing is accused of doubling down on
authoritarianism
and cracking down on human rights
and canadians are caught in the
crossfire
there are two innocent canadian men who
would want nothing more
than to come home the two michaels
kovrig and spavor detained in china
since december 2018
have garnered international attention
and galvanized canadians and their
allies
human beings are not bartering ships
we're going to work together
until we get their safe return when
michael kovrig's wife heard the u.s
president address the case in february
she was filled with hope
hearing president biden say those words
was really emotional
having him referred to michael and to
michael svabor by name
to call for their release um was moving
but in the fight to free the two
michaels another name
has been notably absent
where's the sales case why they want to
bring it up you know why
they don't want to raise it camilla
talandi bayeva can't even flip through
her family photo album
without breaking down when i look it is
so hard
it's so difficult memories of her four
boys
growing up in burlington west of toronto
christmases
birthdays and graduation ceremonies
when i see them i'm very proud but
something is missing you know the
main person is missing in the family
that's
that hurts a lot
she and her husband hussein chalil are
uyghur muslims
who fled persecution in china 20 years
ago
chili was an imam an outspoken advocate
for uyghur rights
he'd been imprisoned in china before for
using a megaphone to broadcast a call to
prayer
in 2001 chalil was granted refugee
status
and he and his wife started a new life
in canada becoming canadian citizens
but he never stopped fighting for the
uyghur people
he was attending the protests in front
of the chinese council
in 2006 the family traveled to
uzbekistan on their canadian passports
to visit camilla's family without
warning uzbek police arrived at the
house
and asked chalil to come to the station
where he was arrested
we didn't have any idea you know what's
going on i was shocked
camilla called her friends back home in
canada one of them knew a lawyer
named chris mccloud they said what do we
do
i can you help i said well no problem
macleod is a commercial litigator
by trade and had never handled any human
rights cases
yeah i just thought we'd phone uh global
affairs
under 1 824-hour number an urgent
message would
be relayed to the relevant embassy they
would send somebody out to clear the air
and have them released but canada didn't
have a consulate in uzbekistan
and another country was quietly pulling
the strings
i started getting calls from people
saying chris this isn't about uzbekistan
it's china
that wants hussein they were right
uzbekistan had arrested jalil at the
request of the chinese
a few months later despite canada's
demand he be released
he was sent to china accused of being a
separatist
and a terrorist jalil was sentenced to
life
in prison i cry every day
like it three four times when i when i
sing about this case
when i think about my husband
china refused to allow canadian
officials to even visit chalil
in prison so in 2009 the canadian
government called
a lifeline hello john
well hello american john cam has spent
the past 30 years
fighting to free china's political
prisoners his shelves are stacked with
binders
full of case notes and letters both to
and
from chinese officials here's a
response in writing his non-profit
manages the world's largest database of
past and present political prisoners
in china containing more than 45 000
names the former hong kong businessman
patiently works within the confines of
china's opaque judicial system
formally submitting prisoner lists for
consideration
the chinese are very patient you have to
be even more patient
and more important than patience is
persistence
you have to keep pushing pushing
but never pushy the tone of his letters
is always respectful and complementary
and his approach has proved effective
over the years cam has helped to secure
clemency for hundreds of political
prisoners
but those victories have become
increasingly rare
it's a bit difficult more than a bit
difficult these days
their relations are quite tense the
chinese government
is not as concerned as it once was with
its
image around the world which at the
moment is quite bad
but they're not as concerned about it
since prime minister harper asked for
cam's help in 2009
he's lobbied for chalil countless times
in 2016
chili's sentence was reduced from life
to 20 years
but there have not been further sentence
reductions to date
so i'm working on that never give up
cam points to the case of canadians
julia and kevin garrett
that's the first place we lived i think
the christian aid workers lived in china
for 30 years before their arrest in
2014.
their case is eerily similar to the two
michaels
accused of spying following the arrest
of a chinese national in canada
the couple endured months of solitary
confinement
interrogated for six hours every day i
remember
during those first couple months two or
three months of interrogation
they threatened execution many times
after seven months
julia was released but kevin was
convicted of spying in a country with a
conviction rate of 99
just when it seemed his fate was sealed
the chinese national whose arrest in
canada had led to the garrett's
imprisonment
suddenly pleaded guilty to spying the
the chinese were
taken by surprise canada's then
ambassador in beijing gi saint jacques
says relations with china were also
looking up prime minister trudeau
visited china
in august 2016 amid talk of a possible
free trade deal
we said we have to use this as a lever
to to bring closure to this case and
they did
two weeks after trudeau's visit kevin
was released
reunited with julia and their children
at vancouver's airport
after 775 days in prison
he's my youngest one he hasn't seen his
debts
jalil's family hoped he might be next in
line
but his situation was about to get even
worse
china handled hundreds of muslims held
in a network of internment camps
in 2016 beijing accelerated its
crackdown on china's uighur minority
accused of corralling more than a
million chinese muslims
into prisons and labor camps china calls
it a de-radicalization program
all those in favor of the amendment in
february the house of commons concluded
what chile and human rights activists
have been saying for years
china's mistreatment of uyghurs in
xinjiang province
amounts to genocide but prime minister
trudeau and most of his cabinet
abstained from that vote and there's
been no movement or any mention of
chalil's case
could you share a little bit about your
engagement on the chiliol case
on the what the chileal case last year
canada's ambassador to china
seemed unaware that chalil was even
canadian
basically because he's a he's not
a canadian citizenship he we are not
allowed to provide
we aren't able to get access to him on
our consular services side we've tried
because he's someone i would like to see
i know it's been a long a standing file
but yet mr chiliol actually is a
canadian citizen
but chalil's canadian citizenship is
irrelevant to the chinese government
which doesn't recognize
dual nationality more than a hundred
canadians are detained in china
many of whom are dual nationals their
names rarely mentioned by canadian
officials
and we just don't see their cases rise
to the top of the list
and it's impossible to deny that to a
certain degree there's an aspect of
racism
uh that that underlies that and i think
that's very troubling
alex neve was the secretary general of
amnesty international canada for two
decades but has never seen a case like
jalil's
imprisoned for so long without a single
consular visit
i think hussein chile's case is is
absolutely
one of the most egregious if not right
now the most egregious
instance of of long-term imprisonment
of a canadian citizen on completely
unjust grounds
but neve also sees an opportunity
western countries
including the united states are now
openly accusing china of genocide over
its treatment of uyghurs
and condemning its so-called hostage
diplomacy
as beijing prepares to host next year's
olympic
games now the world knows they open
their eyes
since the day jalil was arrested 15
years ago
camilla has had no contact no letters
not even sure if he's still alive she
was pregnant
at the time of his arrest their youngest
son zubair
is now 14 and has never met his father
when they were little they were asking
everyday they were asking why he's in
china
i went through so many so many
difficult times now when i see them
how they are preparing themselves the
university it's
it's amazing you know it's
it's amazing you know i'm proud but
something is missing
something is missing my life you know i
really really
need canadian people to help this case
you know
to raise these cases i don't want to be
forgotten this case